IT WILL BE A BEGINNING.
I'VE NEVER SAID IT HAPPENS IN
ONE MEETING, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT YEARS OF HOSTILITY, YEARS
OF PROBLEMS.
YEARS OF REALLY HATRED BETWEEN
SO MANY DIFFERENT NATIONS.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A GOOD RESULT IN THE END.
NOT FROM ONE MEETING.
I THINK IT WILL BE A PROCESS
THAT WE SERVE
THAT WE SERV
THAT WE DERV
THAT WE DESE
THAT WE DESERV
THAT WE DESERVE
THAT WE DESERVE T
THAT WE DESERVE TO
THAT WE DESERVE TO HA
THAT WE DESERVE TO HAVE
THAT WE DESERVE TO HAVE.
THEY WANT IT.
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK WE WOULD BE MAKING A
BIG MISTAKE IF KE DIDN'T HAVE
IT.
I THINK WE'LL HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP AND IT WILL START
ON JUNE 12th.
>>
>
>>.
>> Sean: JUNE THE 12th, BACK ON
IN SINGAPORE.
THE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS CAME
AFTER A TWO-HOUR MEETING IN THE
OVAL OFFICE, WITH THE NUMBER TWO
MOST POWERFUL MAN IN NORTH
KOREA.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION TO
ALL OF THIS, FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT
DR. SEBASTIEN GORKER, SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER, DANIEL
HOFFMAN.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT THE
PRESIDENT PULLS OUT SECONDS --
WITHIN 24 HOURS, OH, NO, NO, WE
DIDN'T MEAN WHAT WE SAID.
WE GOT A MISSILE-LAUNCHING SITE
BEING DISMANTLED, FIRST TIME IN
18 YEARS THE HIGH RANKING
OFFICIALS IN THE UNITED STATES,
WE GOT THE HOSTAGES RELEASED AND
NO MISSILES BEING FIRED OVER
JAPAN OR NO THREATS TO THE WORLD
AT THIS MOMENT, DR. GORKA, AND
HE DIDN'T PAY A DIME.
IT'S REMARKABLE.
>> YES.
LET ALONE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IMAGINE IF THIS HAD HAPPENED
ANYTIME IN THE LAST 25 YEARS,
WHETHER IT WAS REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATION, OR DEMOCRAT ONE,
IF A SUMMIT HAD BEEN CANCELED,
THE NORMAL DIPLOMATIC PROTOCOLS
WOULD HAVE MEANT THAT IT MAYBE
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED A YEAR FROM
NOW.
OR 18 MONTHS FROM NOW.
>> Sean: GOOD POINT.
>> THE PRESIDENT CANCELS IT.
TE HAS A VERY HARD LETTER, HE
PLAYS HARD BALL, BUT HE LEAVES
THE LAST PARAGRAPH OPEN SAYING
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO BOTH OF
OUR COUNTRIES.
IF YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD WITH IT,
SEND ME A LETTER, GIVE ME A
CALL.
WHAT HAPPENS, WITHIN HOURS, A
COUPLE OF DAYS LATER, THAT
LETTER IS HAND DELIVERED TO THE
OVAL OFFICE.
IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING
POLITICS.
DIPLOMACY, AND IT GETS RESULTS.
>> Sean: I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO, I
REALLY AM.
I THINK HE'S BEEN AN AMAZE
I THINK HE'S BEEN AN AMAIN
I THINK HE'S BEEN AN AMAING
ADDITION TO THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, DANIEL,
YOU WERE CONCERNED GOING BACK A
FEW WEEKS THIS YOU WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
ALTHOUGH WE'VE ALREADY GOTTEN A
LOT OUT OF NORTH KOREA IN A GOOD
WAY.
AND THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY
CLEAR, THIS IS A PROCESS,
NOTHING WILL BE SIGNED ON JUNE
THE 12th, THAT IT MAY TAKE, IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF IT WAS ONE
MEETING, IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
THIS HAPPENS, BUT IT MAY NOT,
AND MAY TAKE ONE, TWO, THREE,
FOUR MEETINGS, THEY CAN GO AS
FAST OR SLOW AS THEY WANT.
>> RIGHT.
I WAS A LITTLE CONCERNED AT THE
BEGINNING.
I THINK OUR CITIZENS MIGHT HAVE
EXPECTED IMMEDIATE RESULTS.
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
DIFFICULT CHALLENGE FOR US.
BUT WHAT I WOULD REALLY
HIGHLIGHT IS TODAY'S MEETING,
WHICH WAS JUST SO VALUABLE FOR
US, SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO
HAD MET TWICE WITH KIM YONG
CHOL, THE FORMER CHIEF OF
MILITARY INTELLIGENCE IN NORTH
KOREA, AND THE MAN RESPONSIBLE
FOR THEIR NUCLEAR NEGOTIATIONS.
YOU'RE RIGHT --
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
HIM?
>> HE WAS A FOUR-STAR GENERAL, A
FORMER BODYGUARD TO KIM
JONG-UN'S FAMILY,
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL TRUSTED.
WHAT SECRETARY POMPEO DID TODAY
WAS A WARM TURNOVER TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THESE RELATIONSHIPS MATTER.
THIS IS WHAT WE BASE OUR
PRODUCTIVE NEGOTIATIONS ON,
THESE SORTS OF HIGH-LEVEL
RELATIONSHIPS ON WHICH WE CAN
BUILD FOR --
>> Sean: AS YOU'RE SPEAKING, I
WAS WATCHING THIS LIVE TODAY, IF
WE CAN KEEP THAT UP ON THE
SCREEN WHAT WE WERE JUST
SHOWING, THE PRESIDENT LITERALLY
WALKING HIM OUT TO HIS CAR.
YOU COULD READ HOW FRIENDLY THIS
ALL WAS.
YOU COULD SEE, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE HANDLED WITH A
LETTER AND LEAVE THE PRESIDENT
SAID, BUT IT ENDED UP BEING A
TWO-HOUR MEETING, A LOT LIKE
WHAT THE MEETINGS THAT WERE
SCHEDULED WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA STARTED OUT AS TEN
MINUTES, 15 MINUTES, HALF HOUR,
THEY GO ON FOR FOUR HOURS.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: CLEARLY THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON HERE.
>> TACTICALLY, IT MAKES SO MUCH
SENSE.
WE RELIED IN THE PAST ON
SIX-PARTY TALKS, RUSSIA AND
CHINA DO NOT HAVE OUR BEST
INTERESTS AT HEART.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS
THE PRESIDENT EXPERTLY MOUNTING
AN EFFECTIVE DIPLOMATIC CHARGE
AT NORTH KOREA, WITH SHOWING OUR
STRENGTH, AND AT THE SAME TIME
BEING OPEN TO NEGOTIATION.
WE SAW IT PLAYING OUT TODAY IN
FULL FORCE.
>> Sean: YEAH, AS YOU WERE
WATCHING THIS UNFOLD TODAY,
DOCTOR, I'M CURIOUS, BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THIS PRESIDENT SO WELL, AND
SO MANY AMERICANS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN THE LEFT AND IN THE
MEDIA DO NOT UNDERSTAND HE IS
THE NEGOTIATOR.
>> HE IS.
HE IS A PEOPLE PERSON.
READ THE BOOK "THE ART OF THE
DEAL."
THE FIRST CHAPTER IS THE DAY IN
THE LIFE OF DONALD TRUMP.
IN IT HE'S CONSTANTLY MEETING
PEOPLE.
HE MAKES 40 PHONE CALLS IN THAT
DAY, AS HE'S BUILDING HIS
EMPIRE.
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT RESULTS.
THEN IT WAS ABOUT BUILDING TRUMP
INTERNATIONAL.
NOW IT'S ABOUT GETTING AMERICA
BACK ON TRACK.
AND IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF,
HE'S BEEN CRUSHING IT.
>> Sean: GUYS, APPRECIATE IT.